one year granny's was a publican as well
yeah and then your other brand it was a
granny Bessie yes that is granny Betty's
still around
no sadly she left were both of sadly
left us now but Betty used to be part of
the big family Christmas yeah she
massively and why did you pick because
you'd seem like you picked on that on
granny Bessie not really we she she
loved a bit of attention we we've
obviously done Christmas specials for
the last 20 years and she's all I love
this she's great and she used to come
and do a bit of filming with us she's
very cuddly very gorgeous and I think
Christmas is about family but you know
she used to come and stay with us at
Christmas as well so this is a brilliant
thing to do see do you have Christmas
crackers in America you don't but I just
found out what they are good lad
is it the same one it's not euphemism
[Applause]
hold on yes you put on the play setting
of the what you would call the
Thanksgiving dinner which we call
Christmas dinner and you have the
cracker is basically a empty toilet roll
with another empty toilet roll it's
really weird I think and then you wrap
it up entire little thing and of course
it looks beautiful and then they fought
to make it a bit more fun in the 60s
they put a cap you know from a cap gun
so when you pull it it goes okay and
then you put a joke in there and you put
a present in there and a hat in there
it's normal right
dad yeah
I'll show you a big gift Matthew it's
not you know all of the crackers even
the posh ones have rubbish gifts and I
personally think the jokes are rubbish
as well so I have this thing called hack
the cracker which is brilliant because
you can kind of strategically look
around the table at all the characters
and then you hack into one side of that
the cracker you put out the joke
you pull out the rubbish toy and then
you can procure toys that make people
feel good or bad about themselves right
so in the case of mine and she just got
a new boyfriend after losing my poor
granddad and many years later though I
went into boots and I got an empty
packet it can have an empty packet of
Viagra please and they went yeah please
and they went so I got a pack they were
very helpful and then I got I got some
Smarties and filled them up put them in
there bang him in there and then and
wrapped it up Christmas Day put the name
on the cracker she opens it present
comes out viagra boyfriend next door her
face with that it's only smart isn't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]